في مواجهه براعه الذكاء الصناعي تتضاعف
التحذيرات حتى من بعض من يقفون وراء تطوير
برمجياته وفيما تسارع الدول نحو تنظيمه
يبدو ان صعود التكنولوجيا السريع يتجاوز
الجميع وبعد ان اكد سام اولتمان رئيس شركه
اوبن اي اي المبتكره لمنصه
في شهادته امام مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي اننا
بحاجه الى تنظيم عالمي للذكاء الصناعي قد
تسبب اضرارا جسيمه للعالم من خلال التلاعب
بالانتخابات او التسبب باضطرابات في سوق
العمل او ترويج اخبار زائفه ومثله دقه
اكثر من 350 شخصا يعملون في هذا المجال
مهندسين او باحثين او مديرين تنفيذيين
ناقوس الخطر وطالبوا بتاطير استخدامه فيما
تعلن خدمات جديده للذكاء الصناعي كل اسبوع
وانذر خبراء في بيان ان صعود الذكاء
الصناعي ينطوي على خطر انقراض للبشريه وان
مكافحه المخاطر المتعلقه بالذكاء الصناعي
ينبغي ان تكون اولويه عالميه كسواها من
المخاطر الاخرى على مستوى المجتمع
كالاوبئه والحروب النوويه اثارت قدرات
الذكاء الصناعي المتناميه بسرعه مخاوفه
مماثله من شخصيات بارزه اخرى في الاشهر
الاخيره على الرغم من عدم اعتقاد الجميع
في الصناعه بانها تشكل خطرا وجوديا لكن
ورغم هذه التصريحات المثيره للرعب تركز
الدوائر الاقتصاديه الامريكيه على السباق
نحو الذكاء الصناعي نظرا الى امكاناته
الاقتصاديه فضلا عن اهميته الجيو السياسيه